how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
in yesterday's video we talked about the
anticipation for
the marvel trailers the falcon and the
winter soldier trailer the one division
trailer a new black widow trailer and of
course the eternals trailer but today
we're going to be talking about the
anticipation of the actual
release dates for these shows and movies
because unfortunately right now we
really don't know when they're going to
be released
black widow is scheduled for a
theatrical release on november 6th which
is good news because if that date
keeps we should be on track for other
projects however
disney may be holding off on any other
project besides black widow until
2021 unfortunately and will break
everything down in this video
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all the
latest mcu news and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a gladiator hulk funko pop all you got
to do is subscribe like the video and
leave a comment down below to enter
so as most people know marvel and disney
since they own marvel is pretty
strategic
in everything that they do which
includes when they release things and
what order they release things in we
know that everything in the mcu is
connected and it's widely believed that
the events of the falcon and the winter
soldier will carry over
in some way or form into the wanda
vision series and it's also believed
that the black widow series will set up
some events in the falcon and the winter
soldier like
thunderbolt ross the good news is that
the falcon in the winter soldiers
production
seems to be picking back up this week
there's a set up in atlanta where they
normally film and there's a lot of
production on that set right now no cast
or crew has been spotted yet but
hopefully it's soon but unfortunately
they're not done filming yet and it's
said that the one of vision series has a
little bit more filming to do as well
but here's why the falcon and the winter
soldier may not come out until january
or
february of 2021 this would be about a
three or four month delay because it was
supposed to come out originally in
october and considering the fact that
october
is right around the corner and they
haven't begun filming again yet
it's soon but they haven't started yet
it seems like that october release date
is far less likely
now and another thing that leads us to
believe that marvel will push the
release date for the falcon and the
winter soldier back to the beginning of
2021
is the fact that disney is releasing the
mandalorian in october as some fine
gentleman pointed out on reddit the
mandalorian is going to be released in
october and it's going to run into
december
and to give the mandalorian as much
focus and attention that it needs
disney probably isn't going to release a
marvel show
until after it's done and they won't
release it immediately after it's done
they'll wait a little bit to give people
a lot of time to talk about it so that
makes a january or february release
pretty likely
now some people wonder if perhaps the
one division series could release before
the falcon and the winter soldier series
and perhaps that could
happen but reddit user arcade marvel has
made an
interesting discovery this reddit user
noticed that there is a person listed on
imdb
shane barangu who's listed for both
shows the falcon and the winter soldier
and the one division show
in the falcon and the winter soldier
he's listed as a german
prison guard but in one division he is
listed as a sword agent
so if the casting list for him on both
shows is legitimate there clearly has to
be some continuity here because this is
going to be the same character
which means that his character who could
already be a sword agent who ends up
getting locked in jail perhaps doing
undercover work gets broken out in the
falcon and the winter soldier and then
presumes
his role as a sword agent in the one
division series so
that would mean that the falcon and the
winter soldier would have to release
before the one division series
and it looks like they're going to be
wrapping up the production of the falcon
and the winter soldier before the one
division series anyways considering the
fact that the falcon and the winter
soldier is about to resume production
hopefully this isn't the case but it
does make a lot of sense the falcon in
the winter soldier is not done yet and
the mandalorian is coming out in october
and will last till december so it does
unfortunately seem likely that the
falcon in the winter soldier is going
to be delayed until january or february
of 2021 which of course will push
everything back as well
but hopefully black widow sticks to her
theatrical release date of november
6th sorry about the report but let me
know which marvel series you are most
excited
for coming to disney plus or in marvel
phase 4 in general let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest
mcu news for more chances to win a funko
pop you can follow me on instagram and
twitter i'm doing a giveaway on there
right now
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you